wir hatten Süden und Osten der Ukraine
gehen die schweren Kämpfe zwischen
russischen invasionsdruck und der
ukrainischen Armee weiter und wir wollen
uns heute mal verschiedene Aspekte
ansehen und zwar uns ansehen auf der
einen Seite wo die Ukraine gerade
Fortschritte machen aber auch auf der
anderen Seite wo die Russen wo die
Russen es gelungen ist ukrainische
Einheiten zu vernichten wir fangen an
mit einem Video aus dem Süden des Landes
und sehen hier einen äh ukrainischen
Soldaten der einen Schulter geschütztes
der eine Schulter gestützte Waffe
abfeuert nämlich eine
Igla eine Flugabwehrrakete die gestern
in rason im Süden des Landes
abgeschossen wurde und wir können das
auch verstehen relativ gute Nachricht
für die Ukrainer denn wir sehen jetzt
hier gleich am Horizont dass die Rakete
ihr Ziel trifft
da sehen wir es hier sehen wir die
Explosion am Himmel dort soll ein ka-52
Alligator Helikopter der russischen
Armee abgeschossen worden sein ob wir
hören uns einfach mal die Freude an die
wir im Hintergrund jetzt hören und das
ist interessant diese Freude wie so oft
auf Russisch die Ukraine reden hier
Russisch schreiben da da ich habe ihn
getroffen und so weiter und man freut
sich eben dass man diese Gefahr diesen
Hubschrauber hier vom Himmel geholt hat
das also eine gute Nachricht für die
Ukraine interessanter Bilder haben uns
erreicht auch weiterhin aus dem Süden
des Landes nämlich
im Zusammenhang mit den kamikazen
Kamikaze drohen die Russland seit
einigen Wochen einsetzt zu Hunderten
gegen ukrainische kritische
Infrastrukturen zum Beispiel Kraftwerke
hier eine weitere Kamikaze Drohne die
offenbar nicht mehr fliegt sondern auf
dem Boden ist und hier ist etwas ganz
Besonderes denn diese Kamikaze Drohne
wir sehen hier ist geblirte haben also
die Ukraine etwas versteckt von dem was
sie da gesehen haben und das scheint ein
ganz besonderen Grund zu haben wir haben
den letzten Tagen ja immer wieder gesagt
ja wie kann das sein dass die Ukraine
mit Maschinengewehren an den Himmel
schießen müssen weil ihm ihre Raketen
gar nicht Boden abschießen können was
Sie brauchen ist elektronische
Kriegsführung elektronische
Kriegsführung um diese Drohnen im ganzen
vom Himmel zu holen und offenbar wir
sehen es hier ist ihnen das ja zum
ersten Mal gelungen wir sehen also hier
die die den anderen Teil der Drohne der
noch intakt ist der nicht zerstört ist
das ist diese Shahid 136 Drohne der
Iraner und wir sehen das tatsächlich
noch fast alles da ist jetzt hier werden
weitere Teile der Drohne verscharrt und
auch hier sehen wir wieder gebürt auch
hier wollen die Ukraine uns nicht
verraten was genau auf dieser Drohne
steht nämlich welche Typenbezeichnung
die hat und somit den Russen also nicht
verraten wo genau die Drohne
abgeschossen wurde mit welcher Art von
Waffen sie abgeschossen wurde und wo die
Russen sozusagen jetzt aufpassen müssen
also was sie machen in Zukunft und wir
sehen uns noch einmal an die Ukrainer
freuen sich hier sehr und hier haben wir
die ganze etwa 2,50 m lange Shahid 136
Kamikaze Drohne zu liegen
offenbar haben die Ukraine jetzt die
Waffen bekommen elektronische Waffen
bekommen um diese Drohne auch intakt vom
Himmel zu holen das gute Nachrichten für
die Ukraine wir müssen aber auch uns die
gesamte Realität des Krieges ansehen und
ein neues Video von russischen
propagandaisten veröffentlicht zeigt
hier einen fatalen Tag für die Ukraine
nämlich ein gesamter ukrainischer Konvoi
der hier in eine Falle fährt in eine
Falle die die Russen aufgestellt haben
wir sehen hier entlang dieser Baumreihe
ernähren sich hier eins zwei drei vier
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge der Ukraine und wir
sehen jetzt hier vorne das das erste
Fahrzeug sich auf die russischen Reihen
zu bewegt und das zweite hier zu sehen
ist und wir lassen es einfach mal laufen
und sehen was passiert eine Mine
explodiert unter diesem Fahrzeug und es
kommt zu Katastrophe nämlich dieses
Fahrzeug explodiert man sieht es kurz in
die Luft fliegen und dann wieder landen
es handelt sich interessanterweise um
einen gerade erst aus Finnland
gelieferten xa 185 also ein finnischen
Mannschaftstransporter der 18 Soldaten
transportieren das heißt wir müssen
davon ausgehen dass es hier auch mehrere
Opfer gegeben hat und interessant an
diesem Video ist dass die Ukraine an
weiteren Fehler begehen nämlich das
Fahrzeug was wir eben gerade gesehen
haben übrigens eins von Russland
erbeutetes bnp3 fährt zurück zum anderen
Fahrzeug um zu helfen um eben genau
diesen Soldaten die dort in Gefahr sind
zu helfen und es passiert was passieren
muss das Fahrzeug fährt auf eine weitere
Mine die direkt daneben legt und
explodiert ebenfalls das also analysten
sagen ein großer Fehler der hier
begangen wurde der Ukrainer wir sehen
jetzt wie die Toten und Verletzten
höchstwahrscheinlich abtransportiert
werden und wir sehen jetzt wie Russland
Atelier nutzt um eben die Überlebenden
auch noch zu bombardieren also in
weiteren Schaden zuzufügen und noch mehr
von ihnen zu töten im letzten Bild sehen
wir noch mal die totale und wir sehen
interessanterweise nicht nur die beiden
Fahrzeuge die wir eben erblickt haben
nämlich
nämlich eben das hier brennende
xa 185 und das bmp3 was von den Russen
erwartet wurde sondern wir sehen hier
vorne auch noch ein
M113 Mannschaftstransporter den die USA
geschickt haben auch dieser wurde
offenbar zu Verteidigung geschickt um
eben hier die Evakuierung der
Überlebenden dort zu ja zu zu überwachen
und auch dieses ist außer Gefecht und
steht jetzt hier und kann sich nicht
mehr weg bewegen offenbar hier ein
fataler Tag für die Ukraine die und wir
müssen es einfach sagen weiterhin jeden
Tag 20 bis 30 Tote zu beklagen haben aus
guten Grund weil sie eben vom Westen
noch nicht die Waffen bekommen haben die
sie bräuchten um die russische Armee an
allen Fronten eindeutig zu schlagen
[Musik]